kevin o'leary here AKA mr. wonderful i  have to respond to all the ALS ice  bucket challenges i've received now i  have to pay the price and by the way  I've already invested because I'm more  than 24 hours old so I've given a  donation and everybody should do that  but now I'm going to throw back the  challenge first of all those who  challenge me Mayra King Mike Shanin  Daymond John my fellow shark coming back  at you buddy but I'm going beyond this  not only I'm going to take the dose of  this wickedly cold water I'm jumping  right into a primordial glacial lake  after this is over  oh yeah baby hit me who do you nominate  oh oh oh yeah okay oh my nominating  number one Mark Cuban you need more ice  on your head right now okay Ben Sherwood  the hot dog now number one at ABC  television why not you too lastly  Barbara Cochran my fellow shark but I'm  worried when we throw water on you  you're gonna melt donate to ALS